Israel's president says his country is
going through harsh and dark days hard
to detect perhaps in the autumn sunshine
in West Jerusalem but talked to a few of
those making the most of it and the
shadow of this political crisis is never
far away the country has to be skewered
it carefully and responsibly and we you
know one questions how responsible that
stewardship is going to be in the coming
months for the first time a sitting
Israeli prime minister has been indicted
for crimes he's alleged to have carried
out while in office but there are still
plenty of Israelis who agree with him
that the case is politically motivated
they don't like Trump that they're gonna
get him just as the same thing with with
Bibby a lot of people had enough of him
well he's been there long enough that's
it I'm not saying he's innocent not
saying is guilty in a sense Israelis
have got used over many months to the
details of these indictments the case
has been set out at some length so -
they've got used to Netanyahu's repeated
attacks against the media and the legal
establishment nonetheless what happened
on Thursday night was particularly stark
and it sent a political shockwave
through this country and through a
system already stressed to breaking
point no functioning government the
prospect of a third election and a prime
minister attacking the legal
establishment as he fights to stay in
office the polluted investigation
against me erodes the public faith in
the system they should worry every
citizen we have to put an end to this
Israeli newspapers have featured
editorials urging Netanyahu to resign
for the good of the country some calling
on senior members of his own Likud Party
to engineer it it's not a big chance or
a big possibility but there might be
some cracks within Likud or cracks in
the 55 block of the right maybe because
the indictment now is final
maybe there will be some cracks there
this could be the political influence of
this indictment what's clear is that
Netanyahu intends to fight off all
challenges to his position be they legal
or political and if there's one thing
he's learned in his decades in Israeli
politics it's how to survive Harry force
at Al Jazeera West Jerusalem
Bobby Savile is professor of
international law at the Hebrew universe
city of jerusalem he joins us on skype
from West Jerusalem thank you so much
for your time so considering how unusual
how rare this is is it absolutely clear
that a that a sitting Prime Minister can
be indicted yes but he can claim
immunity he has to go to the Knesset
Israeli Parliament and obtain immunity
and that's a long difficult process
particularly since the it's an interim
government and there's no committee yet
set up to to granting immunity but
there's no doubt it's a long long
process we're not going to see an
immediate conclusion to this so you
talked about the fact you know obviously
there's really this political stalemate
the Israeli government is really in
limbo how does that complicate something
like this out of the head of the to
connect the politics of this and the
legality of it first of all I think you
should point out that it's Israel it's a
sad day for Israel but sitting Prime
Minister is indicted however it proves
that Israel has a very impartial legal
system and that nobody is above the law
so in that sense although it's a sad
occasion Israelis can be proud of their
judicial system judicial systems growing
very slowly so again he can claim
immunity they the diamond hasn't yet be
presented to a court it's a long long
procedure there's pressure on him to
resign but so far he hasn't shown prime
ministers or any signs that he's willing
to intend not only not showing any signs
he's using languages like like you know
an attempted coup having the
investigators investigated when you talk
about the rule of law and the fact that
in some ways it's a sad day but you see
that it's a silver lining that this is
the rule of law are you troubled by him
using that type of language to sort of
demonize the judiciary somebody once
accused you of being a dr. Jekyll and
mr. Hyde in other words as a prime
minister
he's been very sober they careful very
cautious but when he comes to his
personal issues he's a bit he's spoken
in babe vindictive and lost
language so we have the sort of split
personality the Prime Minister on
security issues has been very careful
and is respected however when it comes
to his personal personal life it was a
real problem okay so a million-dollar
question how do you see this playing out
it's just something that can take months
or years I mean it took years for the
indictment to even happen it will take a
long long time
unless political pressure perhaps from
his coalition partners will force him to
resign so far we don't see any signs of
that all right professor
Ravi Sabol thank you sir thank you